you gotta you gotta dance the Quran with
a bow on Katie
and how about the pinpoint page
you can see still down and the timeout
so Koreans in the locker room pardonnez
on all fours go watch it again
[Applause]
it goes out of bounds taking a look at
hardens injured eye you can see eyes
both bloodshot the lights
it absolutely is delights Tucker just
picked up number four showing up the
officials here the officials be honest
he's going to knock it down and give us
the little Steph Curry shimmy out there
Steph Curry
maybe he's fouled as he flips it in and
a chance for 50 from the line
well-contested he went through a warm-up
before the game that's something
standard he did before a game one in
game two in minutes before game 1 in
tune he decided I'm gonna play well
today he said he won't and it's about
[Applause]
the rebound with his right 52 second day
of camping this is really troublesome to
me Amir Johnson is not active but he is
on the bench
that's a cell phone and I can't
definitively say but all of us know what
a text message looks like like what is
that thing doing out to me
why does Joe Allen be looking at thanks
man